je crois par vous dire merci merci à
vous tous d'être venus avec sérénité ce
méli j'ai pris acte de l'arrêt de la
cour d'appel de dijon qui a déclaré que
je ne suis pas coupable de ce dont on
l'accusé cette décision permet de
tourner une page et pour l'église au
lion c'est l'occasion d'ouvrir un
nouveau chapitre
c'est pourquoi de nouveau je vais
remettre ma charge
l'archevêque de lyon entre les mains du
pape françois naturellement si le saint
père souhaite me voir je me rendrai à
rome en mars dernier il avait refusé la
démission en acceptant que je me mette
en retrait pendant la durée de la
procédure judiciaire
maintenant je veux paisiblement lui
renouveler ma demande
mes pensées vont aujourd'hui toujours
vers les victimes
avec bien d'autres frères et soeurs je
continuais continuerait de prier pour
elle et pour leurs familles quotidienne
trier pour moi pour le diocèse de lyon
que j'aime tant pour chacun des
habitants de cette région pour comme le
demande le seigneur pour que tout soit
je n'en sais encore d'être venu chacune
et à chacun d'entre vous je souhaite une
très bonne fin de journée
si vous avez des questions à poser je
vous laisse avec mes avocats
merci à vous tous